and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review kungfu mentor
oh my god this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life there's this
bear who wants to be a kung fu master
and I think he's the bear from those
Panda Express restaurants and so he
climbs the stairs enters this big
Chinese place to become the Kung Fu
Panda pandas will do that I had an art
work that took up tendency until I eaten
and there's a female tiger known as
tigress and there's a female snake known
as snake but do you call female snake
anyway snakes trees this is snake the
snake and all great films have monkeys
remember chairman of the board dad had a
monkey in it wait no that was character
who I think is a monkey and the person
who does his voice is Jackie Chan Jackie
Chan plays a monkey and he says great
things like like I don't like the monkey
parts in this movie you can check each
ant into a points and then he never
talks that's bull crap he can barely
talk already why would you hire him as a
voice and there's a turtle who turns
into flowers I mean it he turns into
flowers but kind of empowers class look
out for the turtle he's gonna make the
room smell like petunias watch out thank
you my whiskey's way to an air freshener
commercial so the Panda is being taught
by a mousy who looks like pinkie in the
brains love child
so the mousy is like or the dragon and
the Panda is like dude I'm a panda
then the mousy is like you're right piss
off but then this great tiger guy breaks
out of prison he takes out like a
million right natural resistances show
the gray tiger and the big panda our
kung fu fighting I swear to God I didn't
smoke anything and the Panda grabs the
gray Tigers pinky and the tiger explodes
she actually explodes more movies mean
exploding great tiger
she knows this one
so much better man had an exploding prey
tiger instead I explored the morality of
inner spirituality of all mankind
what are we ought to go see Kung Fu
Panda oh they don't right between the
real Panda to do kungfu they don't like
that they mostly manyu the next time I
go to Panda Express I'm gonna get a
helping of Kung Fu Panda with an extra
serving of all this is just a repo
saying change change eh what can you
achieve by visa Panda Express the orange
chicken is delicious